anyone else disappointed we
didn't get to see these alien versions
of like loki
[Music]
oh i'm getting real bad at these intro
jokes okay
the girl who died we continue to work
our way through series
nine and we have arrived at another kind
of
two-parter this i find the i
because i don't think i'm gonna remember
to talk about this um
later on i find the way in which
this and the following episode the woman
who lived function as a two-parter
because
it isn't the standard two-parter i know
it ends with the to be continued
but the immediate story is done it sets
up
that there is more but it's not like
cliffhanger it's not like oh the story's
not gonna not finished
no story's done but there's very obvious
follow-up to be done
on it and i kind of wish the show
did that as a two-parter structure more
often
that's not to say that i prefer it to
just literally taking a story and
dividing it in half
the show can do that very well sometimes
but in this particular instance i found
myself going i
kind of wish that it felt more like we
had a two-parters were more like
here's a story here's a sequel to that
story
as opposed to here's one story cut down
the middle i don't know
that just kind of occurred to me so this
is the one with vikings
and aliens pretending to be the norse
gods
and maisie williams as a shielder
who will show up again and uh and we'll
deal with a bit more of that when we get
there so
this one this was just kind of
middling it's pretty good
that said like that's the overall thing
there are moments there are bits there
are beats there are things the doctor
says that i
love actually one of them even made my
top 10 doctor who speeches the whole
thing where the doctor
realizes why he has the face that he has
that's
phenomenal and i love that entire
segment but beyond that he has so many
great lines when he's trying to prep the
vikings winning is all about
looking happier than the other guy
pretend like you already know their
plans and sometimes if you're very lucky
they'll tell them to you
like i love those sort of bits of
bantery stuff and
actually i especially like that second
one because
the way it's structured that he says
that it's like sometimes if you're very
lucky they'll tell it to you so i love
the idea
that he comes in with this swagger not
necessarily because
he's that confident or because it always
works like
no sometimes rarely but sometimes
like in the few times that it does work
it matters enough that it's worth trying
every time
i don't know why that just speaks to me
as like a great quality of the doctors
like well
this sometimes works it cost me nothing
to try it
let's try it on the off chance that
maybe it works
i don't know i i really do i really do
like that beat in that moment
the performances are solid in this as
well um
pretty much across the board i will say
this is not
an exceptionally great use of maisie
williams as an actress
her performance is fine but there's very
little to the character
in this one now she gets a lot more to
chew on
in the next one and we'll deal with that
when we get there but i will say that if
this had been her only appearance
i would have been kind of disappointed
like you didn't take advantage of the
of the actress that you had of the
talent that you had of what she can do
and bring to a part you didn't
do much with it but thankfully this
isn't her only appearance
well i say thankfully there's also the
end of the
thing with hell but oh okay
so we've got all that going on now this
does introduce early on
something that i have railed against
before which is the notion of
of aliens being gods now there's a
couple of things about this that make me
not loathe it i still don't like the
trope but this is not the most egregious
instance
for a couple reasons first off i i do
kind of enjoy that the doctor tries to
pass himself off as odin
only to get immediately shut down by a
big face in the in the
in the clouds so that is kind of nice
and then
like it's established so quickly these
are clearly not the norse gods
established to the audience but also
like
established by the doctor to these
people and they believe him
and honestly just that line that he has
what is the one thing gods never do
they never show up and
i that just that's good and nobody
on the ground acts massively
irrationally because of their beliefs
so this doesn't dip into the main reason
why i hate that trope which is it
doesn't make people with faith and
belief
look like idiots which is the main
reason i hate that thing so it doesn't
do that
and the elements of them pretending to
be
um norse gods is fairly short-lived so
it moves on from that
and we're okay i like that the doctor's
first piece of advice for these people
is just to run and actually not even his
first advice that's also like his second
piece of advice his third his fourth he
just keeps hammering this like
run why are you still standing here you
know they're coming back
run and i love that that is his solution
that
honestly is the most practical solution
under the circumstances
and we're not really given a
particularly good reason why they don't
that is a little bit kind of just
chalked up to them being vikings and
being really pig-headed
which i don't love but also the doctor
calls them out on that
like when one of them goes you know to
to die on
in battle is to die with honor and a
baby starts crying and goes
do babies die with honor i'm like yeah
valid and then to have that feed into
because he understands
the specific things the baby is crying
about and what it's saying because we've
previously established that the doctor
speaks baby
and i like that him hearing that is what
makes him
it's what makes him unwilling to abandon
these people and that especially tracks
given what we now know
about the day of the doctor and how
needing to save the children was the
primary reason he saved
gallifrey like that was the clincher
that was the
that was the thing that took the scales
and ensured that he
had to do this so having a terrified
baby
want help and need protection yeah
yeah he would stay he should stay he
will stay
oh and there's another thing about the
like i know it's explained in episode
that the
fire in the water thing ends up being
electric eels which i didn't bother to
look up are electric eels
native to the part of the world where
this would be set i mean i don't know
i legitimately don't know but um let's
assume for the moment that they
are and so there's the whole thing the
fire in the water
that the baby is crying and the doctor
realizes it's electric heels but it also
occurred to me that there's another
possible meaning of that
and i don't know if this was intentional
if this was done by accident
that's amazing if this was done on
purpose that's amazing
which is that this is the episode as i
mentioned already he looks
in the in the water barrel
sees his reflection in the water and
remembers
the fires of pompeii
he remembers the fires of pompeii while
looking in the water fire in the water i
don't know if that double meaning was
intended but
boy did it make me smile when i thought
of that on a re-watch
i also like the way that the
this uh one handles the idea of the
power of storytelling
because that's that's something that
like it's a
fine fine needle to thread for me
because broadly speaking i like stories
about stories and i like things about
the powers of stories
however the big problem that i have with
a lot of them and
part of the problem i've had with doctor
who specifically at various points
is where yes it's about the power of
stories but it's about the aggrandizing
of the storyteller which given that
it's appearing in a fictional story
feels like writers patting themselves on
the
back for being writers oh aren't we
doing the most amazing thing
ever so that will tick me off and that
is absent in this particular
iteration of the power of stories and i
was nervous for a little bit because
you've got a shield of basically
projecting this story of
a massive serpent into the helmets and
the in the mines and the eyes
of these uh of these invaders so that
they flee
and the doctor does have this moment
where he's like oh you tried to take on
a storyteller i'm like oh god oh no
but then he shifts very quickly off then
says
you know stories are how people remember
you
it's your reputation and what do you
think your story is going to be what do
you think your reputation is going to be
after folks find out about this
and that was a good shift to keep it
from becoming a
and storytellers are the most important
no
it didn't go there it like it gave us it
gave side eye to that idea but then it
went somewhere else i'm like okay
good so let's talk about the doctor in
clara because i keep coming back to this
across this season
and how the development of their
relationship is
building towards what's eventually going
to happen
and i was i was about to say building
towards hell bent but it
we'll see if it properly builds toward
hellbent it's definitely properly
building toward
face the raven absolutely
um we'll see when i get there if i feel
like hell bent is properly built up
and paid off but
what we have here is
we have clara getting uppity with the
doctor
about the fact that he won't tell her
the rules like look
you mess with time you create ripples
and you know you say you talk about
tidal waves but
you just won't tell me the rules and for
the first time
i had a different notion as to why maybe
he doesn't do that
and now this isn't to say that this is
correct or that what i'm about to say is
accurate of previous doctors but i'm
just going by
vibe of the moment generally previously
whenever companions have complained that
the doctor doesn't properly explain
why he can do some things and can't do
others and they
and he asked them just to take his word
on it the general
sense that i got was that you're he's
he's expressing to them your brains
cannot wrap
around this concept i've grown up with
this i know it
instinctively i cannot teach this to you
i just know and so that's the vibe i've
gotten previously
this time i kind of got the vibe that
the doctor
and this has never said so this might
even be me projecting
knowing what's coming later but i did
get the vibe that the doctor here is
more
along the lines of i'm not going to tell
you the rules because i don't
trust you if you thought you knew what
you were doing
that that could lead to some very bad
outcomes if you
actually think you understand this i'm
not going to give you the foundation to
for you to make that mistake so
and again it is just a vibe there's no
specific lines i can cite
to back that up but it was the vibe of
that interaction
and i kind of liked that and it feeds
back into
you know that the doctor because he
knows the rules maybe he's more allowed
to break them but then again
maybe that's a bad idea because you know
what he does for schilder
at the tail end of that moment that i
love so much i'm the doctor and i save
people
and he goes and saves her but he is
openly admitting
i should not be doing this and then he
does and then he
pretty quickly admits i might have just
made a terrible
terrible mistake and
on the specifics of that there's a
little bit of just logistical wait what
the fact that this piece of alien tech
is basically just going to allow her to
live forever
now it will get established in the next
one that she can be
killed but she basically will never die
of natural causes
and it just strikes me as odd that if
this piece of technology
is so common that a race that is
established
in episode to be less advanced
than the time lords can develop
something that basically ensures
they never die unless killed by
unnatural causes
why don't we have way more immortals in
the universe
i i feel like it needed a little bit
more
um tinkering maybe just in the techno
babble to establish that the doctor
like in adapting it for a human
even accidentally souped it up to more
than it was supposed to be or something
because otherwise like this piece of
text seems way too easy to get
and just graft onto somebody and like
why does anybody die
if this thing is so easy so there's that
but beyond that there there's a lot of
good weight
um at the end with the camera move
around
shoulder as her face just becomes more
and more sullen
as you realize the weight of years that
are going on her there is however a
super awkward
interjection again of
the hybrid so first drop we had of this
was in the which is familiar
and it was really awkward there too it
not that the word was
used but how much emphasis got put on it
by the person who said it because it
does not in any way sound like natural
dialogue
it sounds like hey audience pay
attention to this and i think i pointed
that out in that
review as well where missy was like
we're all
hybrids and now here the doctor is like
well she's not really human she's
got alien tech in her she's in a way
a hybrid i'm like oh for god's sake the
the amount of highlighting you're doing
of this word
is painful and it's weird getting
towards it like
i think i feel like right now the jury
is out on some of the
on on the character arc um
aspect of the series arc here in terms
of clara and the doctor and their
relationship
i i feel like i i need to re-watch
straight through to the end to make more
final determination on that
my inclination right now is to say it
works up through heaven sent and then
hell bent
completely blows it but we'll see jury's
out on that
however i would argue that the
hybrid element of the series arc is one
of the worst handled in doctor who
like the concept is is being integrated
into the stories but it's not being
pointed out in
anything close to naturally it's not
subtle it's a
big highlight and it's awkward and
clunky and probably contributes to the
fact that people still don't understand
what the hell it's getting at so
yeah that's the girl who died
it's pretty good there's some good
little moments in it it's not
exceptional
like that's the thing there are some
brilliant moments in it that if the
overall story had been better
would have made a good story great but
instead it makes a
fine story pretty good so that's kind of
where i'm at with this one
you rewatched it lately what'd you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it
i've got all the things you know the
things but i have a patreon
which helps me keep the lights on and
you know i can eat
and in addition to that of course if
you're not able to help me out that way
like share subscribe all of those things
and uh
it would really help me out but you also
don't have to because end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye